sensationsfund artikel aus dem
interstellaren raum gesammelt jetzt
klick zum science fiction
experten der nasa konnten mit der nasa
raumsonde cassini einen sensationellen
fund machen im staub ring des saturns
fingen sie mehrere millionen
staubpartikel 1
bei einer untersuchung mit dem cosmic
dust einer leiser fanden sie 36 partikel
aus dem interstellaren raum also aus dem
raum der unser sonnensystem umgibt
desweiteren besaßen die partikel ganz
besondere eigenschaften zitat die 36
partikel interstellaren ursprungs in
ihrer zusammensetzung sehr ähnlich sind
enthalten eine mischung der wichtigen
gesteins bildenden elemente magnesium
eisen silizium und calcium in
durchschnittlichen kosmischen
häufigkeiten obwohl ein staubteilchen
weniger als ein billionstel gramm masse
besitzt ist darin mit ausnahme sehr
flüchtiger gase der gesamte element mix
des kosmos versammelt solche teilchen
lassen sich in unserem sonnensystem
nicht finden so dr frank postberg
heisenberg stipendiat am institut für
geowissenschaften die forscher waren
erstaunt über die ähnlichkeit der
teilchen viele hatten erwartet die
unterschiedlichsten zusammensetzung zu
finden da sie unterschiedliche
ursprungsorte haben müssten
die partikel die gerade mal 200
nanometer groß sind sind außerdem so
schnell unterwegs dass sie nicht von der
schwerkraft der sonne zum beispiel
eingefangen werden ihre geschwindigkeit
beträgt 72 tausend kilometer pro stunde
der staub sei zudem ein sogenannter
lucky survivor als lucky survivor werden
staubpartikel bezeichnet die es
geschafft haben aus dem interstellaren
raum in ein stern system zu gelangen
so einfach das klingt ist es nämlich
nicht staub wie der denen die experten
eingefangen haben würde in millionen
grad heißen blasen von
supernova-explosionen homogenisiert
erklärt esa wissenschaftler dr
nicolas altobelli in der
pressemitteilung der uni heidelberg
heißt es weiter zitat die aktuellen
untersuchungsergebnisse bestätigen nun
dass die meisten partikel zerstört und
in kühlen und dichten regionen des
weltalls den molekülwolken wieder neu
gebildet werden von dort aus bringen
interstellare winde diese teilchen als
homogenisieren staub in unserer sonne
system zitat ende der staub wird also so
oft recycelt dass er jede individuelle
art verliert und immer gewöhnlicher wird
erstellt also den durchschnitt an
sternenstaub dar in dem von allem etwas
enthalten ist der interstellare staub um
den saturn hat eine höhere
geschwindigkeit als die partikel die den
ringen des planeten bilden und fliegt
auch in andere richtungen und jetzt
gibt's noch mal einen kleinen background
checks zum saturn der saturn ist zehnmal
so weit von der sonne entfernt wie die
erde er benötigt für eine vollständige
umrundung unseres heimatsterns fast 30
jahre
sein durchmesser ist 95 mal so groß wie
der der erde nämlich 120 1500 kilometer
der gasplanet besteht in der obersten
schicht die man bereits untersuchungen
konnte zu 96 prozent aus wasserstoff bis
er sich einmal um sich selbst gedreht
hat vergehen aber nur zehn bis elf
stunden was zur folge hat dass der
saturn an den polen relativ stark
abgeflacht ist die stürme auf dem saturn
sind mit etwa 1500 stundenkilometer
sogar schneller als auf jupiter und
saturn hat genauso einen ziemlich
kleinen aber doch festen kern und der
inneren metallische wasserstoff erzeugt
ein magnetfeld das ihn genauso wie die
erde schützt
eine ausnahme bilden die polen wo die
elektrisch geladenen teilchen in die
atmosphäre eindringen
kommen wir jetzt mal zu den ringen in
den gaz die cassini sonde den
interstellaren staub gefunden hat obwohl
der saturn ring aus der ferne wie feine
gase aussieht besteht dieser tatsächlich
aus millionen von teils vereisten
bruchstücken dabei gibt es sowohl kleine
staubkörner als auch richtig große
brocken so groß wie lastwagen oder
häuser die cassini sonde hat jetzt
verständlicherweise keine lastwagen
großen brocken eingefangen sondern die
kleinen staubkörner mit einer größe von
200 nanometern um sich aber einmal die
ausdehnung der ringe anzusehen die
entfernung zwischen dem einen und dem
anderen ende entspricht in etwa der
entfernung zwischen erde und mond und
trotzdem sind die ringe gerade einmal
einen kilometer dick der ganze ring
besteht eigentlich aus sieben haupt
ringen die wiederum aus hunderten von
unternehmen bestehen und der größte
spalt die sogenannte cassini teilung ist
mehr als 4000 kilometer breit diese
lücken gibt es da sich um den saturn
auch monde bewegen zum beispiel mimas
der für die
spalt verantwortlich ist insgesamt weiß
man von 62 monaten um den saturn
wenn euch das video gefallen hat
inklusive des kleinen hintergrundwissen
zum saturn dann lasst gerne einen daumen
nach oben da und natürlich ein
kostenloses aber und was sagt ihr zur
entdeckung von partikeln aus dem
interstellaren raum schreibt es in die
kommentare
erinnert ihr euch noch an cedric der
hier oft klicks um eine zeitlang eigene
videos gemacht hat mittlerweile hat er
seinen eigenen kanal doktor watson mit
coolen videos zum beispiel zum thema
können computer kunst erschaffen
schaut mal rein link ist unter me und
natürlich in der video beschreibung
ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran